all right I've got another tuna question
for you but it's nestled inside the
extension one paper for what it's worth
extension one it does include the tune
of course so in the extension one exam
you can expect to see a small number
like this of the of the two unit course
in there but they'll give you higher
versions so we're all currently looking
at 13 Part D 13 Part D will focus on
part two number one because I've been
asked and number two because part one is
just about algebraic manipulation it's
just about rearranging so you should
have actually get this this is the
result in part one I also want to point
out I've said this before but it's worth
reminding you suppose you're you're in
this exam and you get to part one and
you can't get this result because for
whatever reason you're stressed or you
do some so now it goes wrong and you
don't get this result okay
do not panic that's fine one of the
reasons we give that this result is so
that even if you can't get that you can
still progress on to Part two use the
result as they've given it to you and
then go ahead and answer part two based
on this idea okay you won't get the mark
of heart one because you can do it but
you can't get some marks at Part two you
can even get all marks to punch it if
you do it correct alright so what we're
looking for is in part two we want the
equation of the normal line eed to
remember what that is at these
coordinates
okay so the first thing you remember is
what's a normal so when we have a look
at a curve this is not this curve I'm
just making something up if you have a
look at a curve when you find where is
it the gradient function what that
gradient function gives you is the
grading of the tangent at any point so
for example here is the tangent at this
particular point okay
the normal is very closely related to
that still goes through a given point
but it's not at the same gradient as the
curve it's at right angles to the curve
so something like this
that guy would be the normal okay now we
know what the relationship is between a
line and a line that's perpendicular to
that so I'm gonna draw on that in a
second
the equation of the normal at this point
okay I need to find the gradient
function first so this is going to
require have a look at that original the
top question what rules is going to
require it's gonna require the question
rule there's no nice neat way around
that and that's a two-unit skill so
let's do that together dy and DX equals
now I always write out the question well
there's so many pieces that it's worth
writing it out Suzy you don't have to
keep it in your brain so I write it as
do you remember it's a wolf watch out
because the question rule it's it's a
minus sign up there if you can't
remember that proposed what the
reference sheet is for this one's
divided by something b squared it's nice
that the quotient rule happens to also
be a quotient so that's sort of easy to
remember I need to know what u and V are
so I have a look up here and I say this
is U this is V doesn't matter which one
is which for the question rule it does
because this guy divided by this guy is
not the same function as the reciprocal
okay so um it's in alphabetical order
like that right now that I've labeled
everything I know what I'm sobbing into
I need to do the differentiation of all
the various pieces so V is 3x minus 5
what's u - in this case have a look 2x
plus 4 there we go good there's a minus
sign yeah and then I go in the other
order so U which is just this by
definition and what's V - it's just
three looks good so far or divided by V
squared which is this how'd that look is
that okay now this looks like a dog's
breakfast but I should be able to get
some simplifying out of this right this
numerator is going to give you a
quadratic here and there's already a
quadratic over there so I'm expecting
some collection of like terms so I'm
gonna need your help a little bit let's
expand this guy one time we should get
four terms out what
the first one 6x squared from that
pairing what about when I paired with
this 12 X okay let's do the second pair
now minus 10x minus 20 okay I'm gonna do
the multiplication by three and the
expansion at the same time so just watch
out for your signs I'm gonna get the
first term B minus three x squared
what's my second term yeah minus 12x
plus 21 okay looking good so far
all divided by now this guy in the
bottom I am NOT going to expand why
won't I expand this I expand in the
numerator why not expand the denominator
yeah nothing's nothing's very likely to
cancel and remember where I'm going to
go I want to use this to actually find a
gradient right so I'm just going to
evaluate the thing I might as well just
have that X all in one spot that's
easier to evaluate than something like
this I'm just hoping to get cancelling
okay that's why I expand so expanding is
not just because I told you to expanding
is because we are going to get a simpler
result in a second okay how many x
squared terms are left behind three of
them how many X terms 12 take away 10 is
to take away 12 oh look that 12 X and
that negative minus 12 X they can just
cancel out actually so that leaves me
with this how's that look is that okay
and what's my constant that's left over
plus one
hmm okay so here's my gradient function
now what I want to do is I want to find
the gradient at this point and then to
get to the gradient of the normal what
will I do with that I'll take the the
negative reciprocal that'll give me the
gradient I need so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna say when x equals two my
derivative will be equal to and then I'm
gonna have to evaluate this thing okay
so this is going to be 3 times 4 minus
10 times 2 plus 1 on 6 take away 5
squared
did I do my substitution okay what
number we're gonna get out of this
conveniently the bottom looks like it's
gonna be one that's nice isn't it
off the top 12 take away 20 plus 1
negative 7 negative 7 so this leads me
to the gradient of the tangent being
negative 7
so therefore the gradient of the normal
and I would want to write this I would
say the gradient of the normal is going
to be their negative reciprocal of this
guy which is there it is because that's
already negative so this one's positive
and this is pretty much all the
information I need because they already
conveniently provided for me the
coordinates now I know the gradient that
I'm after so what will I do with these
two together point gradient form and I
don't need to review that with you right
y -1 1 equals M outside of X minus X 1
and then off you go okay